[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com from the first day that
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
Barr released his four-page letter about
the molo report on the Trump
investigation any thinking person
realized that it did not accurately
represent the content of the Moller
report there was conflicting legalese
there was a sort of deliberately mixed
up use of words like establish versus
find it read like a political document
because that's what it was not sort of a
sober honest law enforcement assessment
and then once the Muller report was
published this was confirmed the molar
report is truly devastating to Donald
Trump and it has sparked this huge
impeachment movement within the
Democratic Party that we've been talking
about but a question that kept coming up
including from people who would call me
during live calls was if Robert molar
really felt that the bar letter was not
an honest representation of the report
that it was deceptive in some way
wouldn't we have heard publicly from
Robert Muller and my answer at the time
and it remains my answer is no Muller
kept quiet the entire investigation save
for like one or two statements that were
made through his spokesperson so I
wouldn't expect Robert Muller to come
out guns blazing and loudly and publicly
saying William Barr is being deceptive
but last night in a this blockbuster
story in The Washington Post
we learned that Robert Muller actually
does think that the bar characterization
of his report was dishonest and he
privately contacted William Barr to tell
him this and this is the strongest
indictment yet of the cover-up act that
William bar has participated in and it's
stunning but also not surprising because
we suspected all along that this was
exactly this
situation The Washington Post has
learned of both a letter and a phone
call from Robert Muller to William Barr
the letter component was sent to William
Barr on March 27th and in this letter
Robert Muller complained that the
four-page memo or as I call it a
propaganda letter which was written by
William Barr quote did not fully capture
the context nature and substance of
Robert molars investigation exactly as I
told you it was deceptive it was
incomplete it was calculated it lacked
context it was dishonest and it was
primarily dishonest in that as a general
as a general sort of concept it framed
the molar report as exonerating Trump
totally and completely which it didn't
actually do this letter that Robert
Muller sent to William Barre reportedly
shocked senior Justice Department
officials that a special prosecutor
would be in such disagreement with the
public statements of William Barr about
his investigation that he wrote a letter
in these terms with this language to the
Attorney General the letter is
devastating but it confirms every single
one of our suspicions here's just one
piece of it that I want to put up on the
screen and read to you quote the summary
letter the department sent to Congress
and released to the public late in the
afternoon of March 24 did not fully
capture the context nature and substance
of this office's work in conclusions
there is now public confusion about
critical aspects of the results of our
investigation this threatens to
undermine a central purpose for which
the department appointed the special
counsel to assure full public confidence
in the outcome of the investigations and
Muller is completely right he spent two
years investigating he found to quote
the report substantial evidence of
Donald Trump obstructing justice found
all sorts of wrongdoing by Trump and
people around him and William bar by
putting out this four-page propaganda
letter about the probe a dishonest
letter undermines the whole point of
even having the investigation you didn't
need an investigation if either way the
Attorney General was going to say
is cleared and he's effectively the
victim here and we now know that Robert
Mulder's letter was followed up by a
phone call which reportedly lasted about
15 minutes
that's one phone call I would love to
hear a recording of and again during the
call Moeller said media coverage of the
report as a result of the letter you put
out is misguided and it's creating
public misunderstandings of what the
findings actually are and the most
important takeaway from all of this as
unsurprising as it is is that this was
the plan all along
it worked the whole point of installing
bar after temporarily having Matthew
Whitaker running the Justice Department
of having Barr put this letter out
before the report so that the media
exoneration tour could be done by Trump
and right-wing media and even some in
left-wing media this was all meant to
prime the pump for people to say no
collusion no obstruction forget about it
I told you that this was the plan all
along from the moment Matthew Whitaker
was put in there and Robert Muller
saying this only confirms it and most
Americans will never read the Muller
report they knew that the bar letter
would set the tone and the content for
most Americans it's very difficult to
fight against that right now
conservative bill kristol
with whom I agree like I I agree with
him basically never he actually had a
pretty good take about this on Twitter
last night he said quote molars report
read without bars coloring invites the
house to at least consider impeachment
now that bars coloring has been as it
were erased how can the White House
avoid its responsibility what's at this
point to be gained by trying
fastidiously to avoid the dread word I
believe he means the dreaded word how
does Bill Kristol become the voice of
reason and then the the next question is
what now molar needs to testify we have
to hear from Muller we have to hear from
molars prosecutors who said more than a
year ago that they determined Donald
Trump did obstruct justice but for
political reasons dropped the idea of
indicted him and there are now Democrats
also considering impeachment of William
bar over what they feel
accurately is William var having hugely
misread misled Congress when he
previously testified we'll find out what
happens in his testimony today the write
and Trump were hoping that the molar
report was the beginning of the end I
hope that this is only the start of the
middle game because there are only more
problems rising that are going to need
to be dealt with I don't know if
anybody's going to face consequences
here I really don't for all of this
wrongdoing but people should and I hope
that Democrats will have both the
backbone but also the political will to
make sure that people are held
accountable for years now I've been
talking about the difference between
democratic socialists and social
democrats and i don't want to redo the
entire analysis again but to sort of
like top line it for you the real
difference is that democratic socialists
are socialists whereas social democrats
are not right the democratic socialism
is socialism in the sense that it
includes socializing the means of
production social democracy is what's
sometimes called a blended economy it's
called well regulated capitalism private
ownership of businesses remains but
there's a very heavy focus on using tax
revenue for a strong social safety net
using progressive taxation to ensure
people don't get left behind that we
properly fund health care and education
and so on and Bernie Sanders has a long
history of calling himself Democratic
Socialist and he may well come from sort
of democratic socialist lines of thought
but Bernie's platform today is not a
democratic socialist platform
Bernie's platform in 2016 was not a
democratic socialist platform
he is a social democrat now I'm not
criticizing Bernie because he can't be a
Democratic Socialist because he
shouldn't be a Democratic Socialist he
can be whatever he wants to be but it is
truly becoming self-destructive for
Bernie Sanders to refer to himself as a
Democratic Socialist when he's not
because it allows the right-wing smear
merchants and the attacks on Bernie
related to Venezuela and Stalinist type
communism or Cuba or whatever
even as a Democratic Socialist those
attacks would be stupid and misguided
but the the the reality is that those
are allowed to be more successful by
virtue of Bernie referring to himself as
a Democratic Socialist now there are
people who are going to hear me say this
and they'll write in and they'll say you
know David the terms have become
interchangeable Social Democrat and
Democratic socialists in modern American
politics it's sort of the same thing
this is really a semantic disagreement
semantics is exactly why this matters
right I agree with you I'm saying there
is a hang-up here about socialism and
communism these are politically loaded
terms nobody benefits from this
confusion and Bernie should be saying
I'm a social democrat in the style of
the Nordic countries and Denmark and
similar countries in the style of the
the Swedish social democracy of the
early 20th century for example these are
capitalist countries that have decided
we are going to use the fruits of the
economy not to allow unfettered
out-of-control inequality and a
shrinking middle class at the expense of
the super-rich becoming even wealthier
but these are capitalist countries that
have said we are going to use the fruits
of the economy to make sure that we
raise people's standard of living that
we provide health care to everybody that
we properly regulate industry which does
not have an incentive to regulate itself
that's the Bernie platform right the the
platform is social democracy not
democratic socialism and the only
defense of Bernie calling himself a
Democratic Socialist is that the meaning
of democratic socialism has changed and
that's not a very good argument okay
most people don't know what socialism
actually is they don't know the
difference between socialism and
communism they don't know the difference
between any of these terms let's not
make it easier for them to muddy the
waters by using the wrong term or
misunderstanding what it is that Bernie
Sanders is we have to contend with the
reality that we have unfortunately
uninformed
or in most cases poorly informed society
in the United States half the country
doesn't vote most people are totally
unaware about basic realities of this
sort don't make it easier for them to to
misunderstand what it is that bernie is
doing by using the wrong terms so here's
my request to you contact the Bernie
campaign tweet them go to their website
whatever tell them Bernie
stop saying Democratic Socialist say
social democrat I agree with the
platform of social democracy that's
Bernie's platform let's use that term
and if you disagree with my analysis
write to me and tell me what's the
upside of Bernie calling himself a
Democratic Socialist when he's actually
not espousing a democratic socialist
platform I'm actually open to having my
mind changed I posted on Twitter earlier
today at D Pakman what are strong
arguments for why Bernie should call
himself a Democratic Socialist even
though he's not the argument that the
meaning of the terms has sort of changed
or become muddled or gray that's a bad
argument I disagree with that argument
but if you have other arguments to make
I want to hear from you I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the
day's James brooch James thank you for
your support I really do appreciate it I
also want to say thanks to today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
Lance
riddle I hope I'm pronouncing that last
name correctly James and Lance thanks to
both of you you can become a member in
under a minute probably under 30 seconds
if you're reasonably comfortable with a
computer keyboard and mouse or your
smartphone at WWJ pakman.com if you
would like a 40% discount use the coupon
code this is 20/20 it'll drop the
membership of your choice by 40% okay
it's time for hate reott mail what is
hatred mail quick reminder it's like
email for words from your racist grandma
on steroids Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right no
introduction needed for this week's
hatred mail recently some hatred males
have required some introduction for
context but not this week's it's
straight up old style Hitler apologia
take a listen if Hitler wanted to do his
Jew killing stuff you're a free [ __ ] a
David Pakman why did he not like Jews
David the leaders of the Jews sold the
Germans out during first world war
god damn you liberals are weak Hitler's
was logical if you understand history I
think that's my problem I don't have a
full understanding of history and
therefore Hitler does not seem like the
most logical and sensible actor in in
the historical record I guess I never
thought about it that way use the coupon
code
Patriot 40 when you sign up for member
ship you save 40% and hatreds cry it's
like sending a middle finger to the
hatreds you're saying you know what your
continued barrage of vile disgusting
depraved and delusional anti-semitic
attacks on David Pakman or David Parkman
as many people write in and say are not
going to be allowed to stand and the
coupon code hatred for tea it upsets
hatreds when people sign up with that
code so I encourage you to do it okay
I'm considering leaving social media
forever period like just getting off of
social media altogether which is sort of
a difficult thing to do
if you host a show like this one that
relies so much on social media and on
being in touch with people on social
media and using social media to spread
the content that we make and I know that
there are some people in the audience
who will sort of react to this by saying
why on earth would you leave social
media but based on some of the emails I
receive and that's a key word emails I
know that there are lots of people in
the audience who will immediately
understand why I'm thinking of leaving
social media altogether and I could go
into sort of like a long sophisticated
explanation of why but I I don't think I
really need to social media is almost
exclusively toxic as a venue in which
people exist and interact and look at
stuff and I'm gonna kind of build the
case up for you one step at a time
first is the kind of like general
perspective later I'll talk about how it
applies to me as the host of a political
show but Jonathan hight for example has
written extensively about the extremely
negative effect of just normal social
media usage on preteens and on high
schoolers at a psychological level and
even for adults the data is more and
more prevalent and overwhelming as far
as this goes which is that spending time
on social media scrolling through your
Facebook feed Twitter feed it's just bad
for our health it's bad for our
psychological health and our physical
health and there's on the one hand the
kind of addictive nature which is
similar to a slot machine just like you
can go back to the slot machine and pull
the lever one more time and maybe you
get something good you can always
scroll down a little bit more down your
Twitter or Facebook feed and you might
get something good and this is this goes
back to operant conditioning this is a
variable reward schedule that applies to
slot machines and it applies to social
media it sort of feels like high school
psychology class this is one of the
things that make social media addictive
and never satisfying because you can
always scroll a little more and maybe
see something even better or more
interesting than the last thing so
that's sort of layer one beyond that we
know that when people scroll social
media you're immediately sort of
automatically starting to compare
yourself with what you see comparing
your life with what's there and when you
compare your life in total with the
curated carefully selected moments and
stories and pictures that other people
are choosing to share it's an impossible
standard and even if we understand this
sort of intellectually as I think most
of us do on a subconscious level it
makes social media really bad for us and
it's not that I spend much time on
social media beyond what's necessary for
the show but there's also the kind of
time element of it if you add up all the
little bits of time that are spent on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram
looking at a comment here checking out a
comment there it starts to add up and it
gets to what I consider to be sort of
the second layer of the problem if you
haven't read too of Cal Newports books
about this you should immediately read
them Cal Newport wrote the book deep
work years ago and it's about the lack
of what he calls deep work in modern
society people's jobs are increasingly
answering emails administrative tasks
all of what I would call shallow work
that's not actually central to what we
do that is valuable in my case like the
real value the deep work that I'm trying
to do is research and prepare stories
for the show to make the content of the
show as good as possible and the best
way to do this is total concentration no
email checking no social media I want to
be doing
of that more of that deep work so it
seems kind of natural to eliminate as
many of those shallow behaviors from my
day that aren't totally necessary and
social media is one of them and then Cal
Newport also wrote another book more
recently called digital minimalism which
I'll interview him about in a couple of
weeks which goes beyond just the crisis
of the lack of deep work but it's more
about the damaging effect of most
people's social media use and the payoff
is pretty damn clear to me if I spend an
hour deeply learning about economic
theory that will actually pay dividends
for the show by virtue of me being more
informed for years to come
whereas if I spend that hour scrolling
Twitter and Facebook I might find
another topic or two to discuss on the
show maybe but it's not gonna provide
anything that really improves the show
over the long term so without even
getting specifically to what's going on
with my social media yet which I will
the need for doing deep work the waste
of time that most social media use
represents there's a really solid case
for at least drastically minimizing
social media use to specific moments in
the day which has been my strategy so
far okay so the way I have been sort of
managing this is that I have in my
schedule as far as work goes in the
morning sometime after I finish up
preparing the day's show I'll check all
social networks I'll respond to what I
want to respond to
I'll make notes about things that I want
to follow up on if there are guest
suggestions people sent me your story
suggestions alright back to personal
messages and then that's it and then
late in the afternoon I'll do another
check but the truth is I have the social
apps on my phone and it's very easy if
I'm on the subway or whatever to just
check in on stuff more often than I'm
kind of consciously trying to so that is
all for everybody that has nothing to do
with my sort of particular situation but
then we get to my social media feed and
it's toxic I mean that's it as many of
you know we get two to three thousand
YouTube comments per day at this point
and I've made it clear that I look at
barely any I mean it's a total cesspool
there's very little benefit other than
I'll look at what videos did well which
videos were heavily liked which videos
were heavily disliked but that's
basically it
and unfortunately my Twitter feed my
Facebook feed it has gotten absolutely
horrible and this is kind of like a
curse of success in a sense the show is
now big enough that any time I go to
Twitter there are dozens if not hundreds
of messages just insults attacks
insulting the show some of its from the
right what really sort of is pushing me
towards maybe abandoning social media
all together is the infighting from the
left people on the Left saying this
person is not actually left enough or
that person is too far left or this
person is parroting right wing talking
points and obviously in small doses all
of this stuff is fine but the
signal-to-noise ratio has gotten way way
too low in most of these cases and I had
a conversation with with Sam cedar about
this in Vegas a couple of weeks ago and
I said I'm thinking about it minimum
getting off Twitter if not all social
media and he said just mute people so
that you don't see them which is fine
but I have thousands of people muted on
Twitter and I don't really know that I
need to be on these platforms it seems
that there's a lot to gain from
screening them out as an example like do
I need to know that some guy with a
YouTube channel did a 15 minute video
attacking me or will I be basically fine
and the show will be just as good if I
focus on my work rather than looking at
who's doing Twitter posts about me and
the only hesitation I have is that part
of the success of the show is thanks to
social media right social media has been
a very important tool for spreading
awareness and the content of the David
Pakman show so it's weird for me to say
I'm completely getting off of it so I
need to think about it a little bit and
in mid-may I'm gonna be interviewing Cal
Newport and this is one of the things I
want to talk to him about which is does
he think I'd be able to get off of
social media given that this is although
it's a radio and
television show it's also significantly
an online show or do I kind of need to
grin and bear it in some sense because
of the importance of social media to the
show maybe I could start looking at just
like verified people's posts on Twitter
but that's problematic because most of
our audience isn't verified on Twitter
so maybe the answer is I just cut it and
I say you know what if you want to get
in touch with me email me actually take
the time to send me an email I don't
know what the answer is but I'm curious
what people think
if you've adopted a sort of digital
minimalism concept into your life I want
to hear about it and one of the really
important things that I want to not
ignore is that whenever people read
about digital minimalism and these types
of issues when people like Cal Newport
write about them the reaction is often a
reflexive that might work for other
people but it wouldn't work for me I
need to be on these platforms because of
XYZ reason and what I am open to is the
idea that that may just not be the case
like maybe it's not actually that
central to what we're doing so let me
know what you think I want to hear about
your social media use tell me if I'm
completely off on this let me know via
email I would say actually take the time
to write for me and I will eventually I
guess make some kind of decision and let
you know where I win the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Renato Mariotti who's a former
federal prosecutor CNN legal analyst and
political legal affairs columnist great
to have you on really appreciate it
happy to be on thank you so let's just
dive right into it my perspective on the
bar team's handling of the end of the
Moller investigation and the release of
the report has been that I think they've
executed it quite well they've executed
it well in terms of the release of this
four-page letter that preceded the
actual report by a couple of weeks most
Americans are not going to page through
a 450 page report understandably they
have jobs they've got to get their kids
to school I understand it and that
letter was a really great basis for what
I'm calling the exoneration tour so like
big picture what's your sense do you
agree that this was pretty good strategy
could they have done better yeah I have
to say it's master deception by Barr I
think it's good for good for Barr good
for Trump bad for America and I what I
would say is that you know what we were
promised with the United States Senate
was promised by Barr was transparency
that he would you know lay out this
report and its findings for the American
people and he failed to do so he
deliberately failed to do so even when
Muller was urging him on multiple
occasions to release the summaries which
really contain everything I mean if if
somebody reads the summaries they
basically get the gist of what happened
in the report
you know Barr deliberately hid the
summaries for weeks while he had this
very highly misleading letter that it
was out there and was setting the
narrative so yeah I agree with you I
think that he misled America misled
Congress and
that's not what an attorney general
supposed to be doing but it worked is a
political matter it appears to work very
well as we've started to learn a bit
about some of the conversations and the
mindset of Muller's prosecutors
throughout the process for example as
one example we recently learned from a
report that a couple of prosecutors a
year a year and a half ago sort of
determined that they believe that the
president had committed obstruction but
that for what are effectively political
reasons the difficulty if not
impossibility depending on who you ask
of indicted a sitting president that it
was sort of let go that's my terminology
not theirs when you saw that report does
that strike you generally speaking as
the type of conversation that
prosecutors would have or was there
something about the generalities of how
those prosecutors are reported to have
been thinking about this that doesn't
line up with how your experience is that
prosecutors behave and talk and think
about charges Wow well I mean here
you're talking about investigation of
the President of the United States and
so the Muller team always knew that the
way this was going to end was going to
be different than the way that most
investigations end okay when I was a
prosecutor I was thinking about what
would my indictment look like what
charges am I going to bring what do I
need to prove to carry those charges and
so the conversation was always about
what a trial would look like what the
evidence would look like a trial and
then for the Muller team who was always
going to be a different sort of question
a different sort of analysis question
was it would always be you know not
anything about a trial or whether or not
they would be able to prevail but
whether or not there would be sufficient
evidence to support some sort of
findings regarding the president or you
know or you know his associates or
things like that now if certainly I
think there were some charging decisions
that were made as to other individual
your rakesh strong brothers but as to
the president I think on the the
conversation was very unusual and
different than a typical conversation
would be and then the separate questions
separate issue is what do you do about
that and Moeller cable came up with one
answer bar came up with another I mean
for Muller the question that the the
conclusion was because we can't indict
it would be unfair to Trump for us to
reach a conclusion that he couldn't go
to court in Rabat in a way that a
typical defendant could bar he had leapt
into this and saying no I mean in fact
his testimony today before the Senate is
no it would be improper not to reach a
conclusion but then instead of going to
Muller and asking him to make the
conclusion he made the conclusion
himself which I think fits with what you
said earlier which is that the goal here
was to deceive or hide or control or
spin or whatever whatever word you want
to use to suggest that he's think we're
giving a picture to the American public
that's inconsistent with the so you sort
of alluding to something that is is
related to this in a way which is that a
lot of non lawyers have issued different
opinions about the importance of the use
of certain legalese in the bar letter
and in the Moller report the use of the
word established in some cases find in
others as one example can you give us a
sense of I mean is that is that a
reasonable analysis to be doing is that
actually going to give us any insight
into sort of what is being said versus
what is being implied or those analyses
not particularly useful are we talking
about I'm sorry you asking about the
Mullen report of the bar letter really
Bo I mean let's start with the bar
letter right the use of did not
establish versus there is no evidence
and sort of all of these different
semantic arguments that were made by non
legal analysts here's what I would say
the bar letter is crafted in a way to I
would say mischaracterized the Muller
report bar was trying to find a way to
write a letter that was technically
accurate so that you could not point to
a word and say this is a lie this
sentence is a complete lie so that it's
technically accurate but it's highly
misleading so he quoted half of a
sentence here or a clause
they're from the report he never quoted
a full sentence when the molar report
and then he used words that were as
you're suggesting soft you know well
didn't establish this you know didn't
reach this conclusion whatever so that
those are not legal terms deliberately
because then this way there could be a
disagreement as to what establishing
meant and so I'd say that the bar letter
was a masterwork
of deception that's that's that would be
the conclusion and I draw I would say
that the Muller report is something very
different
the Muller report is very careful and
guarded and humble I mean I'd say that
molars approach is very humble which is
how we expect a prosecutor to be in
other words if you had a picture of the
ideal prosecutor it would be someone
who's humble who has a sense of fair
play who doesn't go beyond what is
strictly known what prosecutors are
supposed to be that way and
unfortunately they often fall short of
that in real life but Robert Moeller I
think was trying to do whatever he could
to reach that ideal what do you make of
the motivation to include some of the
particulars oates that are in the molar
report just to pick one there's this
footnote in volume 2 I think it's either
like ten ninety or ten ten ninety one
which which in short and correct me if
my interpretation is wrong as a non
legal interpretation it says that
whether or not there is impeachment that
barring some kind of statute of
limitations that that would preclude
this that a president can be indicted
after they are no longer president of
the United States what do you think was
the significance or motivation for
putting something like that in a
footnote I think the motivation was to
explain why detailed findings are being
set forth on issues that aren't going to
result in charges
so typically let's say I'm investigating
a bank robbery okay typical federal
crime well you investigate and then
there's an indictment that's the
document not a report prosecutors
usually don't write reports they write
indict or they don't or they write a
memo that says we decline the case an
internal memo publicly either there's an
indictment if there's not so what Moe is
trying to do is explore
when there's going to be no charges why
go through all this effort to set forth
all the details and go through all the
facts and lock it all in and I think the
the reasoning that Muller and his team
had is that well years later somebody
may try to prosecute this and we want to
have everything set forth in a way that
you know you know makes that possible
you know essentially I serves the
purposes of that potential prosecution
earlier in the program today we talked
about what we learned yesterday that
there was both a letter and a phone
conversation between Robert Moeller and
William Barr we're in short Robert
Miller felt that the if not the letter
specifically the sort of context and
reaction to the letter mischaracterized
the sort of sort of general picture of
what the Moller report found how
significant is this I mean there's the
relatively few other examples that we
can look at to compare what's happening
here - what has happened historically
there are a couple
so can you gotta give us a sense of
whether this is this a big deal is it
not a big deal I was a very big deal
Muller I mean the picture of Muller that
is painted by his report is an
extraordinarily careful man you know I
don't think anybody any lawyer
sophisticated lawyer reading that report
can come away with anything other than
enormous respect for the man in his work
I mean I think it's it's something that
demands it's a it's a work product that
demands respect and he's careful and
cautious it's a moment mentioned a
moment ago and here he is that the days
after the bar letter is released very
pointedly I'd say in a letter pointedly
at least for Robert Muller making the
case that you know he he claims that
that there is a mischaracterization of
the substance of his of his findings in
his the conclusions of his investigation
I think that for Robert Muller that's as
close as you're gonna ever get to
something that is a three alarm fire in
making a very pointed statement very
careful man so yeah I think it's very
significant I think the significance of
it can
laws potentially to the public because
unlike some of the pithy statements that
bar says that are made for television
bar excuse me motorists trying to do
exactly the opposite Muller is trying to
say things in a careful and garden way
and even there he's I think making some
pretty strong statement and really what
I would just say here is you know Muller
I think he is is deal you know dealing
with bar as if he's someone who has
respect for the institution and cares
about doing the right thing I mean we're
ballers telling him is the public's
being misled you need to correct this
you need to do something about it and I
think what he didn't learn until it was
too late is that bar has no shame
whatsoever that even in the face of the
public being misled bar was going to do
nothing for weeks because that's exactly
what bar was from the last thing I want
to touch on and this is really more of a
political assessment than a legal one on
balance based on everything that's
happened until now does impeachment of
the president make sense aside from
whether it's politically viable and
whether any Republicans in the Senate
would actually say yes what what's your
sense of whether there should be such
proceedings well that's a great question
I'm not a politician okay so I don't
I'm not gonna make a judgement as to
what's gonna happen in the Senate or how
all that's gonna work out I can tell you
it's a lawyer that there's you know more
than sufficient evidence to charge
Donald Trump with obstructing justice
and if he had resigned as president last
you know before Muller concluded his
investigation I don't think there's a
doubt in my mind that Muller would have
indicted if he was no longer the sitting
president so Congress can decide to do
what it will with that I you know they
there's all sorts of statements being
made by Nancy Pelosi that it's not in
their political interest to impeach that
sort of beyond my expertise I'm not
going to tell Nancy Pelosi how to run or
political operation but I will say there
is you know more than sufficient
evidence to do so and frankly there's
there's much more evidence than there
wise I think of evidence I would say a
much more serious violation than than
the than the charges that ultimately
resulted in the impeachment of workman
we've been speaking with Varnado
Mariotti
former federal prosecutor CNN legal
analyst and also Politico legal affairs
columnist really appreciate your time
today
thank you very much the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
I told you from the start that I'm not
going to engage in what I consider to be
destructive Democratic primary smears
I'm gonna stick to the facts and the
truth is that sometimes the facts just
aren't great for particular candidates
so as an example from last week or maybe
it was the week before Beto
O'Rourke had no lobbyists as a pledge on
his website and in his fundraising
emails and Beto got caught taking money
from lobbyists and very quickly the no
lobbyists pledge disappeared from the
website and it was gone overnight from
dedos fundraising emails and I pointed
out that this is a factual reality and
it might influence whether you want to
support that O'Rourke or not it's not a
smear it's reporting on realities Joe
Biden raised a ton of money last week as
I told you earlier this week and a lot
of that money it was from big-money
donors high-priced fundraisers including
the executive vice president of Comcast
he has a Google CEO fundraiser next
month these are not smears it's
important to understand that different
candidates are funded in different ways
it's relevant to how they will govern so
I'm going to tell you about it and
similarly mayor Pete Pete Budaj has been
caught taking lobbyist donations and is
now saying that he's going to be
returning the money to the lobbyists and
from now on going forward he definitely
is not going to be accepting their money
39 individuals registered as lobbyists
donated just over $30,000 to Mayor
Pete's so far and the campaign says it's
going to be returning the 30k and also
banning registered lobbyists from
serving as bundlers for the campaign
bundler czar these people who know a lot
of donors and they'll bundle together
large numbers of donations where the
total is way more than an individual is
allowed to donate but they bundle it
from a whole bunch of people and they
bring in a lot of money for candidates
unfortunately this seems to be a change
that Pete Buda judge is making because
he got caught and it looks bad
not because he actually thinks is wrong
to take lobbyist money and there is
really much more to talk about in this
battle on campaign funding because there
are candidates
who might make the decision to limit
their campaign to small donations but
people can still make multiple small
donations to get around that limit
corporate money
what about accepting corporate money or
not accepting corporate money or PAC
money or lobbyist money and the point I
want to make is that this is why we
cover candidates and their funding
ideally when we cover how candidates are
funded it gets them to make the right
decisions but that really only applies
up to a point because as I've said
before you've got to balance this with
strategy if the other side takes all
contributions in the general election
it's going to be tough to win without at
least taking some of that money in the
general election so this is why I'm okay
taking the position now that in the
primary you do one thing and whatever
you say you're going to do you'd better
damn well do it but in the general
election if you're the nominee I think
you have to consider what it is that's
going to get you the win does the
progressive movement benefit by putting
up a candidate against Trump who's going
to disavow so much money that they then
lose in 2020 Wow really great they
didn't take any of that money they did
the right thing I love it except they
lost and now we get four more years of
Trump was that worth it and I don't know
what the answer is so first of all we
have a poll about this on our YouTube
community tab go to youtube.com slash
the david pakman show slash community
and vote on what you think is the right
sort of financial decision that
candidates should make in the primary
and then in the general election as far
as mayor Pete getting caught he got
caught he changed the policy you can
view it as he's a great guy for making
the right decision after getting caught
or you can view him as sort of
disingenuous saying he's only doing this
because he got caught either way there's
got to be an accounting for the general
election because I don't want any of the
money in politics all of this stuff is
toxic and destructive and I wanted out
but I also recognized that if the
Democratic nominee rejects all of it the
Democratic nominee almost
definitely loses to trump in 2020 so let
me know what you think if you needed any
more data to tell you the obvious which
is that anti-semitism and antiderivative
exploded publicly under the Trump
administration we now have the data
anti-semitic incidents were at near
historic high levels for a second year
in a row in 2018 and actual assaults
against Jews more than doubled and there
is actually a long history of
anti-jewish attacks being the most
prevalent religious based attacks in the
United States what I mean by that is
that most assaults in the u.s. are not
over someone's religion but if we look
just that religiously motivated assault
Jews have been the top target for a very
long time and these numbers have
exploded according to the
anti-defamation league's record report
of anti-semitic incidents there were
1879 attacks against Jews and Jewish
institutions last year the data goes
back to the 70s and this was the third
highest year on record now these are not
all criminal actions it can include sub
criminal stuff but it also includes
criminal activity but then we get into
actual assaults there were 59 specific
people who were victims of assault on
the basis of their Judaism more than
doubling from 2017 the most common
incidents are in addition to physical
assaults anti-semitic harassment and
vandalism vandalism is a very common one
very interesting question about this is
how many of these incidents are
connected to known extremists or
anti-semites and the anti-defamation
league and their Center on extremism
have this really large database of
people that are known to them extremists
that are known to them and last year 13%
of the incidents they tracked about 250
were carried out by specific individuals
that are known to the ADL and the Center
on extremism which is the highest dating
back 15 years and this
a really important piece because it
tells us that people who are already on
the radar of the anti-defamation league
and in many cases are also on the radar
of law enforcement authorities are
feeling emboldened enough to go out
there and carry out actions in the real
world even though they're already sort
of being paid attention to and tracked
by authorities and groups like the
anti-defamation league sometimes we have
seen anti-semitic robo calls to people
we've seen anti-semitic flyering
campaigns where extremists will drive
around areas they believe sometimes
accurately sometimes not areas they
believe have higher Jewish populations
and they'll drop anti-semitic propaganda
all over the place we do report on the
show anti-semitic incidents that we
receive to the anti-defamation league
and sometimes to the FBI and from my
conversations with the ADL it is a
near-constant
for many Jewish media people in the era
of Trump ben shapiro
Ben Shapiro a right-wing conservative
who happens to be Jewish a huge target
of anti-semitic harassment online look
at our YouTube channel for five minutes
you'll see that that also applies here
and it would be nice to just hear some
kind of strong statement from Trump
anti-semitic assaults and harassment are
up there is no place for it in the
United States period i disavow fully
anyone who's participating in it and
it's interesting that he's almost
reluctant like he gives these
mealy-mouthed statements only after huge
incidents like a synagogue shooting for
example two of which we've had in the
last six months and it's not surprising
it's a total lack of moral leadership
from Trump and again it's not about is
Trump personally anti-semitic it's not
about well how could Trump foment
anti-semitism his daughter converted to
Judaism and one of his top advisors
Jared Kushner is Jewish it's not about
that things are more nuanced things are
more complicated than that and you only
have to go to what the white
nationalists say I interviewed white
national
leader prominent white nationalist
Richard Spencer on the program a couple
of years ago and he said it's not that I
expect Trump to come out and say out
with the Jews it's that we see Trump's
signaling whether it comes up from his
comments about Mexicans about [ __ ]
countries about immigration Trump is
sending a signal that he's the closest
thing to our worldview that we've had in
the White House for a very long time in
the modern era and that he won't
aggressively go after us and that is
exactly what has been borne out by the
actual real-world actions of Donald
Trump and the effects are visible so
clearly in the data one of the ways that
you can get in touch with the show is
leaving a voicemail at two one nine to
david p you can call that number
absolutely any time of day and some of
you do call very very late but today i
have a email that i want to put up on
the screen for you in a moment i'll
remind you a couple of weeks ago I did
the story about how CNBC had a great tip
a great trick for how to save money when
you go out to eat and it turns out that
the great trick was just tip less right
like just don't leave as big of a tip
and they said you know when you look at
your bill a lot of people calculate the
tip including tax so if you have a
hundred dollar bill in tax was ten
percent people tip on a hundred and ten
dollars but you don't really need to do
that
you can calculate the tip on a hundred
bucks and I pointed out that this is a
just a disgusting trick it's not even
really a trick it's just choose to tip
less keep money away from the often
persistently underpaid waitstaff of
restaurants and I got a hilarious email
from Jim who is taking it a step further
Jim wrote to me and he said hey David I
saw the video on YouTube about the CNBC
trick on tipping I figured this out
years ago when I lived in Anchorage
Alaska where there is no sales tax tax
is tax and should not be figured in on
the amount to tip but I found an even
better trick many places priced their
food too high if I think the prices
prices are too high on
food I tip less typically about 10% my
thinking is that if I didn't come in the
waitstaff would be idle or less busy and
would have earned zero so my 10% tip is
much better than earning nothing
civilization is in trouble Jim yeah I
mean it's sort of genius right like if
your opinion is that the restaurant is
too expensive just take it out of the
server's tip it's a really cool trick
that Jim has figured out I'll remind you
that once again this is one of those
situations where inequality has exploded
to such a degree corporations and rich
people have such disproportionate power
and wealth that even though the real
problem is how they've concentrated
power and run a kleptocracy in which
they decide what are the laws what are
the governing regulations over their
businesses they are almost completely
ignored and instead you have people sort
of arguing over or fighting over does
the middle-class person whose wages are
stagnant deserve to keep a couple
percentage points of their restaurant
bill or does the persistently underpaid
waiter or waitress who is often making
263 or 283 an hour deserve to get those
couple of percentage points worth of the
tip this is by design in the same way
that the immigration debate is all about
is a Mexican person taking my job rather
than about the corporations that benefit
from cheap labor and persistently work
to take advantage of that labor once
again neat trick to save money when you
go out keep the money away for away from
underpaid servers rather than dealing
with the fact that a lot of those
servers are legally paid two dollars in
something an hour it's the wrong
conversation but it's exactly the
conversation that those in power want us
to be having we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the leader of Isis has apparently
released his first video in five years
and there are questions about its
authenticity which we will discuss we
will also talk about you often hear
don't rent an apartment you're throwing
money into the trash buy a house or an
apartment in
said there's a lot of ways in which that
advice doesn't make sense and we'll talk
about some of it on today's bonus show
and lastly a Texas lawmaker ended death
row inmates final meals the tradition of
the final meal before the state kills
you now he wants to silence the last
words of Texas death row inmates as well
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member at join
pakman.com or get accessed by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david
package
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you